Hello doctor, I have decided to stop the immune.
I think it's the aloevia immune
and the blacks of bloodroot capsules, not black paste.
Black sand bloodroot capsules.
And I am, as it seems, I have gotten worse.
So to me, this means they haven't been good for me.
And that begs the question like,
how long should you be on a product before and you reassessing it?
Well, first of all, if you'd ask the question,
how are you reassessing it?
Are you looking at objective findings?
Are you looking at solely objective findings?
You're gonna look at those kind of things.
And how long, let's say some people just start with the plan
or they're just starting with a supplement program.
And they've been on a three month, said their cancer
is continuing to spread.
Does that mean the nutritional program isn't working?
Well, maybe I think it's wise to always reassess things,
but when you go on something new,
it takes months for things to really make a change.
So don't be too quick to make changes either
about saying this question shouldn't,
but just be thinking about that.
The cancer has been increasing in my bone marrow
and my spine, I'm looking into starting the mistletoe program.
How do you feel about this protocol and the success of it?
Well, mistletoe done intravenously
or done with injections can be extremely helpful.
We've had people have done it with a lot of success
and we have had people that have done it
and seemingly had no benefits.
It's just like anything else.
So what may work for me may not work for you
and done there's nothing wrong with trying something to do.